[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the dursleys
vernon petunia and dudley more
specifically
we're going to be addressing their
perceptions of the world of magic
and why their hatred of all things
magical may actually be
somewhat justified let's start right at
the beginning with harry's adoption
when harry's parents lily and james were
murdered on october 31st
1981 the decision was made that harry
would be raised by his aunt petunia
and her family this decision was made on
the basis that harry would be protected
by the blood of lily's sister petunia so
long as he called her home
his own right from the get-go the
dursleys were massively critical of
harry
largely because they associated him with
the world of magic that they so loathed
they didn't like anything that was out
of the ordinary and all of a sudden
petunia was faced with raising her
magical young nephew
they never told harry about how his
parents died never told him about
hogwarts
and they failed to even mention the
magical world to him
they hid harry's past from him because
it pertained to a world
that they hated a world they wanted to
pretend
didn't exist don't get me wrong the
dursleys hated magic in part
due to their personalities which
certainly can't be justified
but in this video i want to explore the
possibility that
as a result of the negative impact that
the magical world had on their lives
they were justified in hating it to a
greater
extent let's take a look at each of the
things that happened to them
and determine which may have contributed
to a justified hatred
towards all things magical we're going
to look at things from
their perspective petunia's hatred of
magic started young
very young petunia desi born petunia
evans was an english muggle woman the
daughter of mr and mrs evans
the sister of lily evans and the aunt of
harry potter
despite her obvious despicable nature
the cold-hearted
evil petunia that were introduced to in
the books and films
wasn't always so bad petunia and her
sister lily
grew up in the town of coqworth and as
they grew older
petunia's sister lily began to show more
and more signs
of magical ability where petunia did not
lily's magical accomplishments started
off quite small
and though petunia didn't think much of
them at first she eventually began to
feel the onset
of jealousy as lily's magic grew
stronger she received a considerable
amount of attention from her parents for
her gifts
and i think that petunia who had none
just
felt left out she did not yet hate magic
though i'm sure that her lack of ability
certainly affected her
in the year 1971 lily received her
letter to hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry it was a
momentous occasion for the family
most of them anyway the youngest
daughter of the evans family was a witch
when petunia saw lily receive her letter
she felt a rush of emotions
confusion anger but most of all jealousy
and despite not being magical she felt
compelled to write a letter to none
other
than albus dumbledore hogwarts
headmaster
hoping to be a part of the magical
school herself petunia stated her case
to dumbledore
and asked if she could study there with
her sister however
given that petunia was not magical in
any way
dumbledore had to politely decline
petunia's request to attend the school
though she was declined entrance for a
good reason petunia felt hurt and left
out
and on this day the jealousy that
petunia felt toward her sister
reached new darker heights from that day
onward
petunia denounced magic entirely it was
a world that rejected her
and the pain that she felt from her
rejection manifested itself in the form
of anger
toward her sister this is where the
hatred all started for petunia
and sad as it is it certainly doesn't
justify
her hatred of magic it just shows that
she's a bit
well petty jealousy is almost never an
excuse to lash out at someone
and to condemn her sister for possessing
traits she was born with
speaks to the kind of person that
petunia was
starting with the first book let's move
through the harry potter story
and see what else could have contributed
to the jersey's general hatred
of magic in the philosopher's stone it's
first revealed that harry's parents
the one who died in a car crash were in
fact murdered by voldemort
in spite of the fact petunia and her
sister had no longer spoke
she still definitely loved her on some
level and the magical world
taking her sister was in my mind
unquestionably
the nail in the coffin that cemented her
hatred of all things magical
justified next it is certainly
noteworthy that baby harry was
essentially
forced on the dursleys though they took
care of him
i say that sparingly it was certainly
not something that they ever signed up
for
nor wanted they weren't paid for taking
care of harry
nor were they given much choice in my
opinion on this point
they are somewhat justified next the zoo
fiasco
in the philosopher's stone harry uses
magic to remove the glass
holding in the giant snake at the zoo to
harry
this was fairly harmless and in good fun
but to the dursleys
it put their son dudley in serious
danger justified
next the letters when harry first got
mail at number four privet drive
he didn't know what to think but before
he got a chance to open it properly
vern and dursley intervened making sure
that harry would never become privy
to the contents of that letter by
preventing harry from reading the letter
and disposing of it the letters only
started arriving
in greater and greater numbers havrick
would read that letter whether vernon
liked it or not
from harry's perspective vernon was
preventing him for reading something
that
belonged to him but from vernon's
perspective
he may have just been protecting harry
trying to steer him away from the same
magical world
that killed his parents the whole
situation drove vernon a bit mad
and i'm sure it all would have been
quite stressful to deal with
justified in an effort to escape the
barrage of letters
vernon takes the family away from their
home at this point they meet hagrid
and after only a brief exchange of words
hagrid is already pulling out his wand
or umbrella rather and giving their son
a pigtail
in order to have the tail removed dudley
ended up needing
surgery which was no doubt a scarring
experience
justified fast forward to book 2 and the
next instance of magic raining on their
parade
is when dobby shows up at their house
and ruins vernon's big business deal
once again unexplainable and terrorizing
forms of magic
have entered his home and his life
messing with his affairs
justified next vernon tries to stop
harry from leaving the home
via the flying fort anglia as a result
he falls out of the window
a fool that could have potentially been
fatal even if fernan had harry's best
interest in mind
this whole fiasco could have been easily
avoidable for him
unjustified fast forward to book 3 and
magic is ruining vernon's day once again
during a visit from harry's aunt marge
but aunt marge suddenly stopped speaking
for a moment it looked as though words
had failed her she seemed to be swelling
with inexpressible anger
but the swelling didn't stop her great
red face
started to expand her tiny eyes bulged
and her mouth stretched too tightly for
speech
in my opinion marge totally deserved
what she got
if this event made them hate magic even
more then that's entirely unjustified
marge had it coming the vast majority of
the dursley's unfortunate encounters
with magic
occur in books one to three however a
few things still happen to them later on
in book four misfortune strikes dudley
when fred and george
intent on getting revenge against the
dersies drop a ton tongue toffee near
dudley
knowing that he won't be able to resist
despite the comical nature of the
situation
for a wizard i'm sure that it could have
been quite worrying for a mughal
particularly as dudley nearly choked to
death justified
in book 5 something happens that i think
justifies the hatred of the magical
world
more than anything else the attack on
dudley from the dementors
of course dudley was only attacked
because he was with harry but he was
attacked
nonetheless an attack by dementor is
essentially an attack on his life
for them to be thrilled but a world of
magic that has creatures which will
attack their son
in their hometown is entirely
unrealistic
justified lastly in book 7
once again as a consequence of the world
of magic the dursleys are forced out of
their home
because of the target on harry's back in
this instance the magical world isn't
targeting them
but rather it has become much closer to
home than they were previously
accustomed
i can certainly understand why having to
pack up and leave their home behind
would incite feelings of anger toward
the magical world
sort of justified in conclusion i think
that if you look at the harry potter
story from the perspective of the
dursleys unknowing muggles with very
little magical knowledge
then parts of their hatred toward the
world of magic are certainly justified
from the wizards perspective with
additional context and
information on magic then some of these
things may have appeared
harmless but we do have to try to
remember
how things would look to an outsider
what can't be justified
is their terrible behavior and initial
entirely irrational
hatred of magic i'm not saying that the
dersies are good
not at all but i'm trying to look at the
other side of the coin here
what do you guys think were the dursleys
justified in their hatred of magic
a lot a little not at all let me know
in the comment section below until next
time
i am not paying for some crackpot old
fool to dj magic tricks
[Music]
you